right
um welcome to the
infrastructure meeting may 11
extraordinary
we're here to talk about the streetscape
the adopting the plan um with us we have
three uh people in public forum we have
joe sharp
bernie brown ben falkens welcome we also
have
with us nick from isthmus tess from tbik
and john green chair of the ccgg
committee
right uh first apologies
i haven't had any we
have on zoom and lindsey mckenzie
welcome
interest rates just there nothing has
been
declared for this so i'm going to go
straight into
public forum now and is it ladies first
or
i've written a wee sleeve
and if you just move the mic up close
is that loud enough is that loud enough
yes that's good
thanks joe okay you so we the way it
works
you wish to each speak yep so you have
five minutes
each to speak and another five minutes
for questioning or if you want to speak
for ten minutes and have no questions
it's your call
yeah four minutes and 55 seconds
okay um so i'm joe sharp and i have the
vodafone franchise um an invercargill so
we're one of three franchises left in
new zealand actually with
vodafone i've been doing this for 10
years in evercargill
and um actually it's coming up to our
happy birthday next month
so it's um and it's been pretty fun so
far
but i'm here to talk about um or to
raise our share concerns
about the impact that the proposed 67
reduction in parking we'll have on
businesses in don street
is the street that is tagged first to be
upgraded
uh the lack of a reasonable parking
solution in the meantime will impact
heavily on
custom access and our ability to trade
i understand the vision for the cbd is
to encourage people to park once
in the 600 plus ico parking facility
and then to have them meander through
the laneways to don street and
other places however this parking won't
be available initially at least
and it may be a cause for customers to
review their shopping habits and shop
elsewhere so there's currently 37 parks
i guess you all know this but
which are a mix of angle and parallel
parks and include
one accessibility park and one loading
zone
the proposal is a decrease to 12 car
parks
including two accessibility parks and
two loading zones
so that's a significant reduction in an
area with mixed commercial retail and
food establishments operating
um parking is already at a premium down
down street and this has been
highlighted in particular with the
introduction of the south and district
council
is attendant in two locations in um
downstream
so this in conjunction with the
construction of langlens and the
cbd upgrade has put pressure on the
meeting
parks available we all have stories of
staff and visitors happily encouraging
not our staff
heavily incurring the cost of a ticket
at an
expired meter due to the cost-effective
nature of doing so
so for many twelve dollars is pretty
cheap for the convenience of an all-day
park
in a premium cbd location so ultimately
the
issue may be a short-term problem but it
potentially makes don street a less
appealing place to locate a business
and business owners may decide to move
premises to where parking is less of an
issue
and so reducing the vibrancy of the cbd
they may even close doors significant
investment has been made in fitting out
the stores on the street
and to have this money and resources
potentially wasted is disheartening
so i've got some potential solutions
that i'd like the council to consider
including changing the wilson car park
on don street the old library or cash
converters building
um to a meted type of park at the moment
you can hire out a park for six dollars
a day i mean so
staff nearby of course use it it's
convenient it's very rare to find a
park available here during weekdays so
if those daily parkers could be
relocated to the 11th street
um library parks and the time available
in the wilson park was
limited to maybe two hours or something
similar um this would offer an
alternative parking option for customers
shopping or eating in the area
so there's 36 parks in that wilson site
so maybe a mix
it's just more having more parks
available
um in the meantime at the very least um
we could also relay reallocate two of
the parks emac for accessibility parking
and loading zones to meter parking as
there's only one of each currently
anyhow
we could change the space allocated for
buses to meted parking
at least until the icl development was
completed
we could change that drop-off zone
there's an area zoned for
a drop-off zone to change that to meter
parking
um and we could review the allocation of
other spaces on the north side of the
street
um so like the vodafone side of the
street or the auction house side of the
street um
because it's really a less appealing
place to hang out
so um because of the lack of sunshine
and the one that comes through there
so all of any of these changes could be
reassessed annually or
in a year to see how the other city
changes impact on the area
they would also offer a less drastic
change to the area
meaning people could find alternate
parking options as the
development progresses um
and thanks for your consideration i was
going to it'll be joking enough it's
appropriate but
no joke's awkward no jokes yeah well i
was just gonna say
it's gonna no it's gonna be lost but um
i was just gonna say um i just wanted to
finish by quoting one of the models on
the um
on the old pumpkin patch building that
um great parking
is what the city needs so
that some people might get it
i might have to explain that which one
of the great models was that joe
it might have been somebody sitting here
today
[Laughter]
okay thanks for that joe now i'm uh
going to ask uh councillors if they have
any questions for joe
and we'll start with marcus so where was
the was the car park that you wanted
them to go to the
uh is it across so it's um
the don street parking kind of behind
the landlands it is directly behind the
landlands build so it's a wilson car
park at the moment
it used to be the old library and after
that it was the cash converters
building it's been pulled down it's on
space street or it's on on dawn street
on dawn street opposite the devil burger
yeah
the space street one is allocated for
tenants um off the building and some of
those are auction houses ten of those
for auction house it's probably a harder
area to reallocate oh copy yep
yeah okay
okay marcus you're good yeah no no sorry
i just wanted to get yes
that sounds like a great idea thank you
i've got that council unlocked i'm good
thanks joe so in that parking area
metered
car parks or paying display yeah i think
it would have to be
i mean just i think wilson's could
probably do it
just so you can only park here for a
maximum of two hours before you're
ticketed
we do it in our space street parking now
they just tick it if somebody's in a
park that they shouldn't be in
or if it's uh well if they're in the
park they shouldn't be in basically
they get a ticket so the same thing
could apply thank you
councillor crackit um thank you um so
these just
over 2100 car parks and the cbd
currently
um and you i
really want to commend you firstly for
um coming to us because a lot of the
time we hear just like
a lot of complaints and a lot of
solutions yes and so i really wanted to
commend you for putting forward some
solutions based
um ideas of you know like here's a
problem maybe you can look at doing this
so
that's fantastic but for um my question
was
the surrounding car parking areas you
mean you've mentioned the the wilson's
one you've
got the cbd one here for council there's
one also
beside the old aaa opposite martin and
lob and there
is the council library car park do you
see all of these just like
too far for people can little
constituents to walk down don street
especially the one just by his best i
think if you see the way
people shop and i know it's going to
change with the cbd development
um i think it's just a little bit far
along
for the meantime like people don't like
that kind of change so
dramatically and so that's where i'm
concerned that their shopping habits
will potentially change because they
can't get a park and so going from 37
it's huge down to it's actually less
than 12
i think will be it'll be hard very hard
and they won't walk well i mean they
could park across
right now they could park across at the
library park at the moment and just walk
across the road
it's less than two minutes but they
don't and they won't
so that's why i'm saying can we be a bit
more creative or a bit creative or some
just another idea on how we can get
people
shopping there review it as you will
and as we need to with the develop like
the 600 plus parks that go up
um when they're once they're established
but in the meantime i think it would be
remiss not to consider some an
alternative solution
and being that we are first off the
cards and the main development won't be
finished
why not probably exactly cool thank you
for the questions uh i've got one joe um
look what
a lot of the time now for me to get a
coffee state auction house
i just park in space street um just it's
it's two-way and i know that uh there's
always a park somewhere and use the legs
so yeah yeah do you find many of your
customers will do that
just yeah we get a lot of well auction
house have team parks
no no but i mean out on space street
yeah people do that it's
and it's become hazardous as a result
because like without having east
street the traffic has moved into dawn
but more so into spay
and so there's no pedestrian right there
across to for example taitai
that's quite popular and so if you've
ever walked across that way
it's uh it's quite don't and busy
dangerous and busy because of so many
people park on space street as well
it's a leap of faith yeah you're right
that's right we have people parking in
the space street parks
and um because they're going to nakita
or wherever they're going on space
street as well parking is
it's tight it's hard at the moment and
there are alternate sites but people
just won't walk
hopefully they'll walk once the
development happens and the parking is
available
and i'm sure they will i'm i've got a
great deal of faith in that
but i think we need a stepping stone
in the meantime right
no further questions thank you joe we've
got that under consideration
yours your suggestions on that wilson's
park
thank you right welcome ben
thank you thank you cheer hear me all
right yeah no good perfect good
all right well thank you for the
opportunity to speak today um
unfortunately due to only receiving this
information
at five to five on thursday afternoon
there hasn't been enough time to gather
feedback
from the nrg members so while i cannot
speak on behalf of nrg i speak today
here
as ben falcon's local business owner of
shoe clinic
situated in the heart of this street the
communication the communication process
to date hasn't been very effective or
efficient
i personally feel i've been chasing the
answers since since we last saw the
drawings at the 50
stage earlier this year so no retailers
have
really been included in consultation
since then
with that being said i do support the
new layout of this street
but i would like to see a couple of
changes the main change i would like to
see
is where you have removed the parking
place and placed extra seating
outside scout steelers eb games hong
kong
and shoe clinic this area needs to be
better utilized as car parks or loading
zones
the plans show already ample seating
opportunities on the south side
and as well as the crossing from sit
arcade to the new development entrances
this plan allows only for 15 car parking
opportunities
down esk street currently please keep in
mind that loading zones will take up two
to three oh sorry three to four of these
parks
and one or two of these parks will be
for disabled um
car parks only leaving nine car parks
for destinational shoppers for about 25
businesses
currently situated there
please also don't underestimate the
disruption to all business owners
while this upgrade is going that this
upgrade is going to have
i go back to my five main concerns i
raised the original hearing
march 2019. number one maintaining the
vibrancy throughout the rebuild
number two getting the project completed
in a timely manner
number three presenting all retailers
with a clear timeline so we can manage
staff requirements
and potential store sales if needed
number four maintaining ongoing
communication
number five signage and to help the
public and visitors
navigate their way through i'm asking
you today
what are you putting in place to to keep
the communication with us retailers
currently we have a fantastic process
happening with icl with regular
fortnightly meetings
receiving all up-to-date information
which we can pass on to other retailers
and discuss with public when they are
shopping if we have the same process
implemented throughout the city upgrade
this will help immensely with
communication and relieve any undue
stress
for all retailers and staff
i cannot stress enough how hard this
will be for all retailers in
the central city we're not only
concerned about our businesses
but also our staff's livelihood i ask
that you respect this and that you have
the process in place
so we can all understand and work
together to complete this project in a
timely manner
for all this to be achieved we will we
will need full involvement from all
parties
council contractors and retailers thank
you
thanks ben okay i'm gonna open it up now
for questions
counselors
counselor manager when you say that you
have uh fortnightly meetings with the
ico
who exactly is it at with the the
builders and the contractors or
with the coms lady or yeah so
jeff cotton the developer is present
or project manager along with the comms
of amy hibbs myself bernie rochelle
and other business that may be
needed at the time yeah so it's just a
select group of you
from nrg and then you feed the
information back
right what i can say ben is that later
on during this
process um one of the people speaking
will be russell pearce and he'll be
covering the very topics that you've
brought up
regarding the construction stage thank
you cool
okay no more questions there bernie
thank you very much mr chairman and uh
your worshiping counsellors i'll just
bring it a wee bit
closer sorry i'll just pull it forward
thank you very much
uh for the opportunity um to speak today
um a lot of what i've got to say is on a
positive note
and i haven't crunched the the numbers
the way that ben and joe so adequately
um have but i'm speaking as an
individual
esque street retailer who was passionate
about the city that i've lived in for
more than 70 years
since the march 2019 consent process
we have consistently and fully supported
the invercargill central rebuild
and through challenging times the
retailers on the north side of esk
street
have striven to maintain some vibrancy
and energy in what has been firstly a
demolition
and now a construction zone
the streetscape and upgrade at esk
street
the vision for pedestrian friendly
spaces and garden areas
is admirable but it has to be balanced
with the reality
of what is currently working and does
not need fixing
from 30 esk street our workplace i've
had 23 years
of daily observing the flow and
behaviour of people in
cars and people on foot
we are mindful of the needs of all
people
particularly the elderly and disabled
who deserve
easy access to this area
the multi-level car parking building
will not
be an option for many of these people
on the street there is an overwhelming
preference for angle parking over the
proposed parallel parking
you only have to watch people not
necessarily elderly or disabled
attempting to parallel park to drive
this point home
invercargill is a business centre for
the whole province
and we have to appreciate that the
tokunui farmer
the bluff fisherman and the tiana
motelia
come to the city centre to do business
quickly
and smoothly and return home
they do not require green spaces or
playgrounds they have their own
they do not need obstacles put in their
paths
many of these people like our own city
people are time
poor the future of the city is exciting
the completed rebuild will be a game
changer
it is to be hoped that the old and the
new
the big and the small the north
and south sides of esk can work together
to enhance the esk street experience
all the little guys need is a voice and
an even playing field
i think it is fair to say that up and
down the country councils are embarking
on new inner city projects
and not all have met with universal
approval
in fact from as far north as auckland
and as far south as dunedin and gore
there has been much discontent expressed
in the media
about certain aspects of such upgrades
if and only if such reaction should
occur here
we'd have would hope that council would
address any issues head on
and to be accountable for any flaws in
the planning
that need to be rectified and take the
appropriate action
thank you very much for your time thanks
bernie okay
councillors questions for bernie
i think i'll get a chance to speak later
all right i've got no questions
no probably won't let you you know cause
something in here
alex i've got a question um so you
you've obviously
had a good look at the comprehensive
preliminary drawings at the moment
um and you'll notice that outside i
think it starts at around shoe clinic
that
out there's um a common area where a lot
of the
furniture street footage is modular and
removable
with the idea to create a bit of a open
space or piazza where you could have
like a farmer's market or
an event to matariki or whatever we have
in
a city do you see that that sort of
vibrancy to be able to have that in the
middle
of that street rather than you know the
intention of wonga place was always to
be something like that but obviously
isn't functioning that manner
in that manner do you see that as a
positive oh very much so
and as a street we have embraced those
occasions when the
street has been closed down for matariki
for market day and other such occasions
where it is
you know predominantly pedestrian
and that's for the greater good and the
overall
um you know picture of things but in the
day-to-day running of business
it's it's access and convenience that's
the key yeah okay
thank you uh we've got council analogy
then councillor clark
thanks bernie you've been in retail for
a couple of years now
um can you describe how the
the traffic pattern has changed from
the years when friday uh was the big day
and friday night
uh to to now and and the shift to
seven day trading how that's affected
traffic flow
well i think the general pattern of of
business
is that there is no pattern and um
a sunday can sometimes be better than a
saturday um
once upon a time the friday was the key
day but um
and again it's the trips to town
way back in the day the farmers would
come
less frequently than what they do now
and
you know even today observing um
the traffic pattern um you know people
traveling south
on d street making a left turn
into esk street because of the
restriction with the cones today you can
see
how easily things get held up
when um you know people are wanting to
go straight ahead but there's an arrow
to go
to the left turn and there's cars backed
right
up to the lights at don street because
you know it doesn't work it's uh but the
flow
into s street with that angle parking
goes very very smoothly
the people are on a mission when they
make that left turn into east street
they're looking for a place to park they
park they do their business they come
out
and move on and somebody else takes that
part
council clark yeah bernie just one
question about
with your knowledge about the local
scene and the national scene
and tell me if i'm getting this wrong
but are you saying to us that the inner
city retail
will be enhanced by being close to the
mall
and that eventually having more foot
traffic than car traffic around that s
street area and potentially around don
as well
will be advantageous for retailers and
so is it just an issue how do we
how do we get to that spot which might
be off in the distance a little bit
is that the issue for you or are you
saying that that
after we get the the work done the
limited parking is still an issue
um i think there still needs to be
street level uh parking in esque street
that
um in addition to the parking building
as i say there's a there's a lot of
people that are not comfortable driving
up to a multi-level
um you know car parking building and
um you know it's an unknown
um the effect of how things will
um unfold as it were once the
um the city centre is built and it's
fully operational
i mean there'll be lots of new retail
players
in the marketplace and again you know
nobody rests on their laurels and
you keep raising the bar to see that
your brand is strong enough to draw
people
out of there to look at you as a as an
option
um as it were but
yeah it's the same with the the um the
ilt with the hotel build
that all the people in the periphery are
there it's an unknown what the patterns
how it'll affect other nearby
restaurants and cafes
um yeah the reason i ask because i
looked at napier recently when i was
here and
they've got a similar situation of a
short street like s street
and they put some bollards in and
they've owned the only car parking is
what we're suggesting
with this was parking team so you had a
drop off or something you could go to
one shop but you couldn't browse much
longer than that because you
end up with a ticket and i asked a
couple of retailers on there
sort of what was it like and he said
there was an adjustment period
where um some people stayed away because
they couldn't get a car back
but eventually the foot traffic overtook
what was traditionally there which was
people coming in getting out of car
wandering through and then getting back
into their car
he said the foot traffic did pick up
because people are attracted to
areas where there aren't cars there's a
drift towards that and so retail had a
bit of a
an adjustment period which it was a bit
hard for one of the shop owners i talked
to
and he said but it subsequently picked
up i just i just wondered yeah
there's um an interesting aspect of that
is
um the weather aspect yeah and and one
of
um you know russell's comments to the
press uh
about things when somebody asked about
uh closing s street
entirely and he said it's been a topic
for 30 years
and i can recall it being raised at
different times and
often you know when people said at that
time could have been back in the 80s
i don't know but they'd say oh it'd be
great to close this all off it'd be
great to close over esque street
um and as a it's generally stated on a
very
sunny november day where everybody's in
a feel-good factor
and as i pointed out um you know to the
person
that we operate 12 months of the year
and
that in a cold bleak july day
you would be praying for a car to come
outside and park
somewhere in the street to give you some
of the
that vibrancy and energy that's talked
about
we haven't heard the suggestions since
this morning bernie
right okay just one question bernie um
what would you imagine what would be the
maximum parking time in those e street
parks
for someone would you would you drop off
time or
half an hour for a shoot a suit in and
buy a suit or 30 minutes is
is is pretty good and you know
people may only require 20 of the
minutes and they'll go
my new menswear shop you know people men
make up their mind pretty quick
but at least they've got an opportunity
to um
you know be able to do something
in that time um so 30 minutes top
yeah stops right okay
now that's all uh marcus one more yeah
if you notice that with the
kmart's got a pretty easy pack you know
it's all enforced and with pick and save
as well
is that giving you guys a lift with
street traffic or is it too hard to tell
with the
demo anything it's it's pretty hard to
to tell we have had
feedback from a lot of people
who formerly would have traveled to
dunedin
to go to kmart on occasions and we've
had dunedin people
who have been in our store who have come
down over a weekend
to do some kmart shopping for the family
and they might park there and find their
way to your place is that what they'll
do
i think they do the kmart thing get in
the car and drive
yep right
okay thanks guys that's well now now
we're going to move on to
um presentation from john tess
and russell and nick
so
welcome john thank you uh it looks like
we're ganging up on you with four of us
doesn't it
um first of all uh your worship mr
chairman
elected council council team and
um gallery thanks for the opportunity to
come along
and bring along the preliminary design
to you
for approval to proceed to the next step
uh the intention is i'm just going to
speak briefly as chairperson of the
governance group
and then hand over to the experts but
before i do so i'd just like to
acknowledge
the input from the three previous
speakers the clarity
the honesty and you know putting
forward i think some really good
commentary and
again responses to the questions you put
to them so
i think it's a really good example of
the process working
we're all familiar with the process to
date
you've heard from me probably too often
and you've seen
most of the work as it evolves now we do
need to remember the primary design
is now only just over a week old
and since we saw it at the workshop last
week
the challenge now is to move from
planning and creative
to doing and we shouldn't underestimate
that
this doesn't mean that the planning
won't continue to evolve
and there's no doubt that the volume of
feedback will increase as the plans
become clearer
as new detail creates new advocates and
new objectives
the challenge for the project team will
be open to be open to feedback and input
and adjust where appropriate without
destroying the intent
of what's proposed we need to recognize
that the impacts will be significant and
the disruption will impact on some much
more than others
again the team's challenge is to
mitigate these impacts wherever and
however they can
they do however have a very tight time
frame as we heard at the workshop
last week and it's in everyone's
interest to get these initial stages
completed as quickly as possible
but we do need to front foot the
objections and the concerns
and we need to find remedies for those
oh as
nick takes us through the preliminary
design and he'll just speed date you
with that
because you've seen it before i would
ask you to remember that this
work is the product of community input
it is the product of
collective experience of a large number
of people both locally
and people who do this stuff for a
living that's something we need to keep
in mind
we're not on a flyer we're not out there
to reinvent the world
we're out there to deliver a in the
cargo city centre
for them for cargo people in the wider
southing community
along with our visitors so we'll hand
over to nick and
sure
thanks john um firstly apologies i'll
just bring it a wee bit closer if you
can
obviously apologize i got dressed early
this morning and i seem to be in
designer black
landscape architect with usmas i
lead the master plan process with
russell and and council
and now leading the streetscapes project
as well
so through the master plan process there
are really four
issues um identified the first being
around a perceived lack of pride in the
central city
the second being a lack of energy and
vibrancy within the city
lack of places for people to to actually
be be present in the city
um and poor connections and by poor
connections that's
people feeling like it's hard to get to
the city and then once in
hard to move around so as we move
forward
on this in any future stages of
streetscape work
we need to make sure that these issues
are being addressed
so the vision as we've pulled it
together for the end of 2022 is that
esk and don streets are completed by the
council and in parallel
icl's mixed-use development is open hwr
tower is well underway
and i alt's langland's hotel is open and
thriving
and the community pride in the central
city is restored
at least well on the way to that so
people return
they spend time and money in the central
city with that newfound pride
so how do we get there uh well firstly
it's about making the central city
uh a comfortable and welcoming place to
be
uh and to spend longer
it's easy to get to it's easy to get
around
and and once here we want to be able to
extend people's time here
so that means multiple reasons to come
and multiple reasons to stay
people bring in kids grandparents
bringing their kids bringing their kids
uh and so forth
so when it comes to design of the the
streets uh we've got three
simple moves that we're making in both
don and esque straights
the first is to acknowledge uh
the environment that we're within um and
the idea of facing the sun with your
back to the wind has come up
um a lot and that's driven the way we're
actually structuring
the streets and where we decide to put
places for gathering
creating a simple structure within the
streets in a variety of spaces
and that in part comes down to
councillor crackers comment before
around flexibility in the street so
sometimes the street is a place to move
vehicles
and people sometimes it's a place to
actually gather
as a community and the third is around
playful movement so not just movement as
a chore i need to go from a to b
actually enjoying being being able to
move freely within the central city
so the right hand side are the left hand
side sorry
talk simply about the space that we've
got allocated for
for people for gathering space on both
streets
don street has an eight meter wide space
on the southern side of the street
that's where the sun is more often and
it's where you've got your back to
the cold southerly wind and more ability
to get out of the westerly
and on esque street that's wider again
that's a 10 meter
space diagram on the right
just talks about the permeability within
this within the city
so with the development of icl
linking into the arcade and then through
into auction house
there's a great pedestrian route to get
you through the city easily
undercover for the vast majority
and when you're within desk street
there's the ability to move freely
it's a place for people first and
vehicles are visitors in that space
also worth acknowledging that the icl
development have put a lot of effort
into
making sure that that whole building
edge is permeable for people
so people can uh enter and exit through
the main entrances as well as through
all of the tenancies along there
and we want to make sure that the spaces
within the city are playful and playable
as well and so that better we in part
the idea of trails or connecting
smaller features together making sure
there's enough space
for for social and passive play knowing
that there are groups of community
teenagers for instance unlikely to to
play in the
in the playground fashion but play for
them is about being social and
being together sitting on an edge and
watching others
and really what we wanted to explore the
idea of water and light and how that can
generate energy within the straight day
and night
and pulling on the environment for color
and that that's in part around
color that gets gets applied to elements
within the street and partly about how
we think about light
so it's more than just a functional
requirement of lighting a street
it's about how we get flare in there as
well
so esk street's designed as a shared
space
with a consistent paving material across
the full width
and it's about people first vehicles as
visitors
vehicles are all vehicles are able to
move through the street
and the parking is focused on the north
side of the street
making more space on the south um in the
sun
out of the wind for people to gather
in the center we're proposing what we're
calling the clearing
it's a flexible space that's populated
with movable furniture
um and that furniture is able to be
moved to the sides to create a venue in
the center of the street
and in part the clearing provides an
ease of movement from the icl
development through to the arcade
also worth noting that the seating
elements
particularly on in the street face north
and for the most part east the idea
being that
people want to face the sun and planting
behind can can provide a bit of buffer
from the wind
insight lines across the street from uh
from the north side retailers to the
south side and vice versa
up free and open
so this is the shot looking from wow as
you've just come out of
sit arcade looking towards the kelvin
this is a raised timber platform that
faces onto the
onto the clearing um the idea being that
at times it'll be a seating space at
other times it'll be a social space but
it can also be a place for performance
both to organize and impromptu
and this is a view as you turn from d
street into
into esque so facing towards hwr tower
with the kelvin in the background on the
left-hand side there
you'll see there's substantial planting
in here and the planting is in part
about aesthetics about seasonal color
and and it's also got a function in that
it's it's a rain garden so it takes
water from the
from the paved surfaces it cleans it
through natural processes
and then it puts it back into the
stormwater system
don street uh changes from being a
one-way street to
two-way as was proposed and agreed in
the master plan
uh and the vehicles move on an ashvale
carriageway
there's three raised tables along the
length of the street
uh one at each end to signal to drivers
so they're entering a street that's
different
and they're expected to behave
differently
uh and then a raised platform in the
center
which provides easy connection through
again from the arcade
through to auction house
without the need to step down onto the
carriageway and then back up
so it's pedestrian-grade the whole way
across the width of the street
there
so this is a view facing towards d
street
the idea being that again the planting
is as per esque street
it's doing some some good environmental
work as well as
providing high immunity in the street
and we've got a series of
seated elements or seating elements
in both streets constructed from timber
natural material
warm comfortable dries easily
and will encourage people to be there
for longer
and the shots outside the uh langlands
hotel
so the langlands hotel is set back their
facade is set back from the boundary
creating a space that's quite similar to
say batch cafe
so it's north facing it's set back out
of the wind it's going to be a sun trap
and it's going to provide activity on
that street edge from the restaurants
and cafes along that edge
so ultimately the the project aims to
develop an invercargill for invercargill
this is not about isthmus coming in and
telling you
uh what you should be doing it's about
thinking listening to you thinking about
it and reflecting back what we're
hearing
um building on the existing qualities of
the place
and developing at the same time
developing a new look and feel
brings new energy to the to the city but
it builds on invercargill's robust and
stylish personality
so strong and independent strong and
independent without too much of us
so i'll pass over to tess now to talk
about programming
thanks nick good afternoon all um so i'm
here to talk about the
delivery program today um acknowledging
this program
as john has mentioned is incredibly
tight
the program has been developed um around
the priority projects being the langlais
completion of the langlens hotel
and the icl development to integrate
with those opening dates
so i'll start on don street um and as
has been mentioned
we're underway with a three waters
renewal program on don street
so that started on monday this week
and that three that three waters renewal
program will run
until august 21 and then
in in august we're going to start the
streetscapes work on dawn street
so we're going to start on the west end
of the street and we're going to move
east
so we'll be starting at d street where
the on the corner where the new langlens
hotel is
and the first section of streetscapes
works that we will do will take us from
d street to the sit arcade
we've done it that way to achieve the um
opening date for the langlens hotel
which is december
this year january 2022 so we'll be
finished that section
from langlens through to sit by
january 2022 and then we'll carry on
through don street
and we will go from the sit arcade up to
the top of don street to kelvin street
and will be finished in don street by
may 2022
so we'll be we'll be there from august
21 doing the streetscapes work through
to may 2022.
on esk street our intention is that we
need to do a sewer renewal on esk street
before we start the streetscapes work
so that sewer renewal will start in
august and it will run through
until november this year and then we'll
start the streetscapes work but we'll
take it from
a different end so we'll start on the
kelvin hotel end of esque street on the
east end
and we'll work our way west and we will
get to where the new
entrance to the farmers will be by april
2022 to align with their opening date
and then we're going to split off on esk
street and our plan is that we're going
to go to the north side of the street
so that we can finish the streetscapes
work where the
operational retailers are by july 2022
and so that we can get out of their area
and we can then
move across the street and from july
2022 to october 2022
we'll finish the works on the south side
of the street
so on esk essentially we're saying we'll
be doing work on the street
from august this year until october 2022
okay thank you
all right russell afternoon councillors
just a very brief comment about um how
we will manage this
the city centre is certainly a busy
place at the moment but certainly once
we start to do some streetscape it'll
become
busier and i guess what we've been
looking to do is how do we actually
manage that and we see the importance of
actually
i guess caring for our city caring for
our retailers
we want this process to make sure that
we are honest and upfront about what we
want to do
and we can engage as early as we can
have that information and
some of this preliminary design work
we're just now getting to a point where
we can
share it um we will actually we will
have team
um with our contractor within our
project team we'll have some
communication people
but we'll also have their city centre
coordinator and all those people will be
able to
um work together in a much
the same way that mr falcon's talked
about having those fortnightly meetings
getting together and there's lots of
information we want to make sure that we
pull those
all those i guess projects and stories
together so that we can communicate
um i guess once with the retailers
rather than many times and actually can
confuse them there are a large number of
stakeholder groups that we continue to
have to connect with
and engage with that includes the
property owners and the retailers
and we along with our contractors so
there's quite a lot of moving parts on
this
big game plan we are looking to
make sure all of our utilities do it
once and my target is to make sure that
we don't dig again for 10 years it's a
pretty lofty goal last time we
had a reasonable success but the idea
being is if we can get all those things
right we can do it once
and then avoid any disruption
just a little comment about some of the
options for car parking
so i'll preempt the question perhaps a
little bit is that we are continuing to
work with
options in in don street and we
acknowledge um
that there are a range of options we can
envisage about how we can actually deal
with some of those parking issues
that works
um i just like to wrap up i'm just
making a note
around you'll see in the report that
there's a statement in there
around budgets for this project
you'll recall that as part of obviously
the investment that's happening
in the city centre at the moment that
council had committed
20.8 million dollars to upgrading our
streets
at originally when that money was
allocated it was hoped that that money
would be able to cover both stage one of
this project
which is is the stage you've just seen
um but also stage two of the project and
that stage is the section
of kelvin street from dawn along to tay
street
and the remaining section of esk street
from kelvin street
through to this building now we're at
the point where we've obviously finished
preliminary design for stage one
and based on the costings that we have
worked through for stage one where it's
17.7 million
for that stage that leaves us with what
we consider will be insufficient
budget likely for for that's to get us
all the way through that stage two
now we haven't actually stepped into
preliminary design for stage two so
we've still got a lot to work through
there
we just wanted to make sure that in the
interests of transparency
that we made both council and the
community aware that
where we are actually sitting with
costings on stage one before we actually
finalize that design and move forward
into construction around those
additional costs for stage two that's a
process where we're going to have to
come back to council as we finalize the
preliminary designs for that stage of
the project
and look at whether or not we continue
with the full scope for stage two
whether we increase the budget and what
the impact will be going forward
thank you erin right um
i'm going to actually what i'll do is
we'll can we get the recommendations up
on that
thank you all right
we have four recommendations to council
so um i'm gonna ask for a mover and a
second down and then i'll open the floor
for questions
move counsellor scalp second
councillor sopa right
uh questions uh we'll start with
councillor kit and councillor munson
thank you mr chairman uh i
what i've seen i've been lucky along
with others here this is the second time
i've seen this presentation
absolutely impressed by it a bit nervous
about the
cost but one thing
that we've had problems in that street
is the parking over the years i just
look back uh
when i see me retired at the age of 65
i'd spent
54 of those years in that city block
working
starting off as a message boy t
ass crowd jewellers tay street
originally when the two lane to a
single way street one-way system came
into place
55 years ago eskindon
we were traveling the opposite direction
down esk street
and had to face turning traffic to four
right hand turns to go around the block
they didn't listen to the people back
then and ten years later they'd
realized they'd made a mistake uh back
then
when the there was parking meters
everywhere i think it was about 80 car
parks
when they done the inner city upgrade
20 odd years ago i was
on the working group and we made some
mistakes back then and i said a couple
of years ago
18 months ago when i got re-elected that
we don't want to make mistakes again we
want to do this
and have it right for the next 50 years
what i'm not happy with is the plan
of reducing the parks down to eight
parallel parks
angle parking has been a huge success
very easy to maneuver into and v
very easy to exit and it won't take up
that much extra room you see people
trying to parallel
parallel park now and other streets they
park that way
far from the curb so if you put parallel
parking there you're still going to take
up a lot of the carriageway
very easy to maneuver into very min easy
to maneuver out very
safe quick and and no hold-ups
they shoot everyone most importantly the
elderly
they absolutely love them uh
ask mr pearson have the elderly been
consulted
age concern or grey power
but i believe we could put them in there
without much
trouble maybe cutting down some of those
planters by about a meter
we need as many car parks as we can get
for the elderly
we have now over 10 000 pensioners
over the age of 65 and that number is
growing fast
um and we've got a number of people with
disabilities
including my wife and myself and there
are specialty
retail outlets in the esk street that
they visit on a regular basis
uh so that's what i've got to say i just
hope that
you can give us some assurance today
that if age concern
and uh great power haven't been
consulted
could they be consulted and i'd like to
be in the mix
with the people to do to talk to the
next stage but i can't see much
problem uh and putting in angle parking
you can increase your park from eight to
about 16.
i think you could do it easy can i don't
know if you can give us assurance on
that today i'd like to think you can
another be no no no assurance today
unless you want to
speak uh russell um thanks mr chairman
there's a there's a there's a couple of
points that i'd just like to
bring we have um during the master plan
we talked to both
um age concern and grey power but i
guess
the preliminary design has been on the
agenda and we can go out to the
i guess those groups again with the
information now that we have it
available in the public
public forum just a couple of
i've did some numbers while i was
sitting at the back and we've um
we know that the icl development will
have about 675
or thereabout car parks and i quickly
added up what we have in 11th street
and uh h j smith's have across the road
here and that's about
490 car parks so that car park building
will actually
double that plus another equivalent of h
j smith's on
available as the number of car parks one
of the things that
nick and the team have been working
really hard on is
um west street is about the street is
about for people and i guess
vehicles are visitors is sort of my
catch cry at the moment a little bit
and what we do know is that um angle
parks
need a longer stall length and they
actually will reduce the space that's
available for people so i guess that's
the balance that
has tried to be reached in this design
and s street really is a place where
short-term drop-off occurs not
necessarily
longer terms and i think east street
will have lots of adjacent
car parks
just one further comment if i may look
history tells us you build a fantastic
building with hundreds of car parks
uh it does not necessarily help the
retailers across the road
just look at 11th street with the big
red building there
when that was developed all the
retailers that went to that area
think they'd cream it well look at ftc
it didn't help them did it they're
moving into the
new central block so just take that on
board
okay thank you rebecca
thanks i've got four questions if that's
all right and i'll do them one at a time
starting with the easy one and possibly
the dumbest one um
i noticed in the planning for don street
that the end with the langlins is is
going to be done
sooner rather than later and i also
notice
when i've been down don street that the
langlens has big boards
down in the middle of the road so i'm
assuming you've worked that out so that
the timing is
that they're going to be gone and you're
not going to have to go back and just
yeah so
we're working with the langlens and the
icl design teams and their contractors
as well
um to to coordinate when the hoardings
need to be pulled back so we can go in
and start the streetscapes
cool i think it's a really interesting
point that's been raised with the public
forum
around shifting traffic
from esk street and don street into
other streets
and i noticed sometimes when there's
been road works in other parts of the
city
that all of a sudden a a set of traffic
lights means that
cars are banked up for like three blocks
because you've narrowed it down for two
lanes and things like that have we taken
that into account
for the work that's going ahead that
we're not going to create
hazards like in space street or um
you know big dangerous things uh by
shifting traffic out of those places on
a temporary basis
mr chairman we certainly have and we
have just been working through what we
describe as a network
operating framework the new acronym
and that really looks at how where cars
should be
and where they are so what the streets
are purposing for so
streets like space street will be more
purposed for being a circulating street
whereas
we're seeing esk street and don street
as being civic places so
there's a new classification so that's
the intention and that's how the city
will work
better so people will circulate around
and go to those places
next question is around changing
people's behavior because
it does seem very clear that people in
invercargill
seem to be hell-bent on wanting to park
outside the shop
that they want to go into and
um how do we change people's behavior
when it comes to do we have any
suggestions i i
i know joe mentioned about we need a
stepping stone do we have some
options to use as stepping stones or
do we have some ideas or do we just
change things and make people
change their behavior because they have
no choice
who's going to answer this one well i
think we could probably
all take a piece of it and um well we've
got different perspectives but
i think a few meetings ago
here i talked about um
confronting this issue that people don't
like change
people love change people embrace change
they fear loss
and you might recall me saying that the
key here is to get out there and
communicate about
what you're not losing and to
come up with things that mitigate
anything you may fear that you're losing
um there's some skilled communication
required and some good thinking required
some clarity
um but i think it's about working
through those and that's why it's really
important that we had
you know the the contributions that we
had in public forum
is to pick up on those themes and go
right what other ways either to address
these issues
room for a little bit of creativity but
also room for a bit of pragmatism
i guess ultimately um you effect more
change with a sledgehammer than you do
attack him
um but at the same time um i think it's
more about being respectful of the
arguments put up
and just working through them i don't
think there's a magic answer
right thank you oh nick do you want to
well i i guess my two cents would be
that
um the cargo city centre finds itself in
quite a
unique position and that almost a full
city block is being redeveloped which is
immediately going to change people's
behavior
and has actually changed it already so
you go down esk street there's
hoarding's up
parking is limited and people are moving
in different ways now
that's not necessarily the way we think
people should keep moving
but they used to change in this area so
we see the ico development and the fact
that the recording is up and there's
going to be cones up
all of that will change people's
behavior through construction
and we want to reinforce the right
behaviors
as part of that construction phase so
that when the project opens
people are used to moving in a different
way
anyone else russell no i've got
one last one last question um
so the whole thing around i guess
engagement with the community as we go
through this process and i know that you
mentioned lots of people in your team
that are going to be helping with that
but do you actually have anybody who's a
specialist in community engagement
as part of the team because
personally i believe that engagement is
quite a different thing to
communication and all of those other
skills and expertise that you need
and this seems like a big project that
having somebody with those specific
skills
would be quite valuable
i'm very confident that our team will
actually have all the skills that we
need to do so
right is that that's good so just to
update on who's next we've got council
of adelaide councillor crackit then
councillor clark
all right we're your worship you're on
the list
right council adelaide thank you chair
no questions just comments i had a good
chuckle bernie
at your suggestion of 30 minutes parking
would be adequate because it takes me 30
minutes of conversation in your shop
before i even start looking at the racks
so i admire your optimism um
the master plan was
a massive consultation collaboration and
and it's it's good to gather as many
groups and to try and make sure that
you've you've got everybody on board but
at the same time the the flip side is
that there are some people
who are going to feel um perhaps
disenfranchised if their views aren't
reflected in
in the outcome um i i keep
hacking as as we've gone through this
process
back to the 2000 upgrade that we did
and it came at a time when his worship
will recall we had zero fees
happening at sit so a whole lot of young
people came to town
the city centre looked good everybody
felt great
and and the one thing that keeps me
going through the end of the war zone
that we're living in at the moment
is at the end we're going to have
something quite great people are going
to feel
really good about it and i'm i'm looking
forward to that you know i commend the
energy retailers for the attitude that
they've
displayed through this process and
through the
city block process as well um i think
councillor keith raises a good question
around parallel parking which is which
is worth considering
because despite the fact that many
modern vehicles come with rear view
cameras
um it hasn't come with an innate ability
for people to be able to parallel park
and you know i still see vehicles three
metres out from the curb
where parallel parks exist around town
so i'm a little skeptical about that
we've been told throughout this process
that there's a there's a lot of pressure
there's time pressure there are some
really time critical
deadlines that we've got to meet um at
the same time as this potential pressure
around
workforce availability um products to
to to do the work and and everything's
tight financially we're already seeing
that
that
being tested so that's something that we
appreciate being kept up to date with
and and we've got to keep an eye on
but i want to come back to to a point
that um
that ben made during public forum and
counselor evans and just touched on and
it's around communication
and and you know being who's been
involved in the in the process right the
way through
felt that from thursday to today
was not really a lot of time to go and
digest
something that's that's this large
uh during the workshop last week i i
asked about um
disabled access because that's something
to key to
my business um and and i'm in the war
zone
and said that it's around making sure
that there's there's good communication
and and we had it in the in the 2000
upgrade
and and we need to make sure that we
have it again it's just
we may have started with a hiccup at
this point which
you know is is not great i still feel
that we're on the right track i hear
russell when he says he's
sure he's got the the people on staff
that will be able to do it but it is
something
that we have to stay on top of the
retailers feel that they're being well
serviced communication wise by
uh icl and that's great and we need to
um use that as as a benchmark for for
what we're going to do thank you
we have uh council cricket uh thank you
councillor pottinger i've got two
questions uh one that's probably
most best positioned with tess when
we're looking at
um the project team or um who we're
going to end up tendering with is it
part of the criteria
um with the contractors that they'll be
will be requesting that they do like
fortnightly meetups
very similar to what nrg is currently
doing with icl
absolutely so we're requiring the
contractor to have a dedicated comms
person
who will be able to communicate with
retailers on a day-to-day basis or on a
weekly basis essentially whatever is
required
to ensure that they are kept up to speed
and then that um
comms person will work with the icc team
as well
and the icl team and the ilt team to
make sure that there's there's a
there's a consistent message as well
because we don't want to confuse people
around
different initiatives different groups
are going to be carrying out okay cool
thank you i think that's absolutely
paramount
and my second question is along the
lines of what joe
has requested today in public forum
do we have any ideas of initiatives or
anything that we're talking about with
parking in the inner city to try to
move some of those long-term state
parking stays ship them out of the
cbd a little bit more while all of this
is happening so we can get some
repetition or fast movement of traffic
so people can come in and out rather
than
taking all of that long-term stay up
we continue to look at options and we
have been looking at some other options
for
dawn street to increase some extra that
short-term type parking which is really
how you will actually set up those
either a space or on street so
i think in the in the preliminary design
it indicates that
both don street and east street will
have
shorter term parking so you won't be
able to park there all day
so we've also got other initiatives
where we are actually allowing with our
new meters to come on stream and to
actually
have different parking regimes in
different places so
we do have quite a range of different
parking options for instance
like 11th street has a has a number of
people who have leased parks we have
some p90s on the roof so
each of those locations have different
options where we can encourage people
to actually go to places for longer
stays where they want to and shorter
stays in other places
i just want to carry on from that sorry
thank you um
the current loading zone just as you go
in the
um into esque street a couple of shops
down
it's a loading zone but it's currently
used as a drop-off zone when there isn't
anything being loaded in there you just
see people
zipping and zipping off and that kind of
thing do you imagine that with the
current drop-off zones or the prospected
drop-off zones and escape will function
like that or do you see people probably
staying in there for a bit longer than
they should
certainly in this street some of the
parks will be allocated to
um i guess a loading zone for people but
we also would equally expect
the streets of being a relatively smooth
slow moving nature that if someone wants
to drop someone off
they could easily just stop in that
space and drop them off because it's not
going to be a fast moving street so
and in don street we currently have an
area
suggesting that there is a place for
just simply there to just drop off so
that you can
come in and drop people off and then
they can
go to the shops thank you okay
councillor clark
yeah i've got two or three uh
reflections and one question for russell
so
um aaron has raised with us twice now
about the
stage two impact that we don't have
enough funding for that so i guess
from a personal perspective i'd just
like to signal that that will require
either additional funding
or a decrease in scope or a combination
of both
just to make that work in relation to
what bex raised about changing behavior
i asked some of the retailers in napier
how that had gone because they did a
very similar exercise and they said when
you decrease
car parks and you have them as
short-term stop-offs they i think they
had
p-15s people stop rotating through the
street because they know they're just
the odds of getting a car parker low so
only elderly people who are prepared to
go around the block two or three times
will try and get one and the rest just
parked somewhere else
so that that helps um like peter
said and i think others have said as
well i'd like us to think again about
the angle parking in s street
i think uh from my observation because
of my um
addiction of going down to get uh
starbucks coffees every day i see people
attempting to
do the parallel parking and it's an
absolute disaster
and so and i've had quite a bit of
feedback from retailers about that so i
think
be able to look at that again would be
great and just as a last question for
russell
bernie has mentioned that darren comes
in and spends 20 minutes in the shop
before he gets his jacket which takes 10
minutes and has suggested that maybe the
parking in there which i think you said
was going to be
p15 p20 it
is that possible to be a little bit
longer like vernier suggested which is
p30
now from what i analyze from that
that'll allow
some retailers to have a bit more
quality time with their potential
customers
but it will potentially cut down the
amount of availability of parks
so that has two impacts one that
decreases the car traffic through for
retailers but it also
encourages less of the rotation round
people go also and walk to bernie shop
so i just wondered about the p20 versus
p30 thing
mr chairman i think our intention is
that we would either have it as p15 or
p30 and that's certainly something that
we can work through in the detailed
design
along with which parks are allocated for
disability parks which
parks really how many loading zones or
how many um
restricted time is in the p30 packs i
think if you have the long
if you have the time too short it
doesn't it's hard to
enforce if you have it too long it
actually defeats the purpose of what
those parts are there for
yeah so just one question in relation to
that
is there some ability to trial it and
then if it doesn't work to
adjust it councillors i think every part
you are able to change by a by-law
change to actually set what you wish
and um it may may or may not even have
been
a charged meter it could be a free
period thinking
um just a point of clarification for all
councillors
and um is that regarding the parallel
parking and the angle parking
in this preliminar preliminary design
that we're adopting
the option is for parallel parking that
is correct russell
and so if we adopt this we are not
uh going to be looking at the parallel
parking options
that sorry the angle parking options so
this is the design so
um one question i had around parallel
parking in a
people friendly street is
backing out now
i've i've done parallel parking scares
the hell out of me
with the produced room behind or someone
walking or whatever
you know fair enough modern cars have
have the odd camera or something but
and the length of vehicles i went to a
functional transport world
on saturday night and they've got angle
parking out there
we pulled up on our suv which is a
medium-sized car
and this could have been a ranger or a
colorado or whatever
far out it pulled up beside us and it
went forever
and it was sticking out you know right
into the road
and the the vehicle lengths these days
in size
so i'm just wondering you know the this
this angle parking thing
mixing it into a people-friendly
area to me just as
not it's just oil and water it just
won't work
and so that's why i'm reminding people
now we embrace this
people-friendly concept the design
is if we adopt this we're going for
parallel parking
that is correct nikken yeah
we would be recommending that you would
actually continue with parallel pay
right
okay sorry i'll just i thought i'd
remind everyone about that your worship
your next yes thank you mr chair the
only issue i had and it seemed a
relatively minor one is that
um it's was
known when i first arrived here as the
city of water and light
and i thought it was great but people
saw it as water being rain
and light being lightning and we quietly
filed it away somewhere i just wonder if
you know what happened to that
currently we were a city with heart
and electric vehicles
any um any other discussion
counselor skill oh just not a question
but just a couple of comments really
this is what he
um approached the team which is an
incredibly experienced team we've got
sitting in front of us here
the gentleman that's been involved in
the canterbury rebuild on white head
over a period of time so there's a great
deal of experience sitting in front of
us
i'm really really excited about the
multi-purpose multi-functionality
test in particular around that event
space
and i think the more multi-functional
that can be
and obviously that's the design and the
ability to move that furniture
the more we can do with that that the
better will be it's a great event area
and what we can create for the retailers
i think will be fantastic for
joe bien and bernie and want to thank
joe bien and booney for coming in today
i think it's been really worthwhile
and certainly we can certainly look at
those and find solutions to the
immediate term anyway um where you're at
i love the face of the sun and back um
back to the wind
that's fantastic whoever came up with
that
we talked about change behavior and it's
really interesting because
there's many many as example examples
throughout the world we don't have to
reinvent the wheel here
it's just about communication it's
simply about the way we communicate
the fantastic story we're moving to um
the parking's are nonsense in my opinion
we've got i love the actual visitors as
vehicles
must have that you come up with that i
just think it
is where we need to be going forward we
do take a leap of faith
this is not new around the world what
we're trying to create here
we've got a fantastic opportunity we
just have to nail it
thank you councillor kit yeah thank you
could you put a number five in there and
and
uh the wording to the effect that the
design team
look at angle parking opposed to
no we can't do that we we are presenting
the reason we can't do that is we are
presenting a preliminary design and the
design
is in front of you for adoption so you
have
okay why you can't it's only something
minor i i think you can
um i'll let the gm speak to this
um so what i just want to state is that
um
when we discussed this one previously
we've spoken about the fact that
because of the timelines that we have on
this project we need to move immediately
from preliminary design
into detailed design now what we're
bringing to you is the preliminary
design the picture of what this will
look like and we need to now move into
the detailed the engineering decider
side of that this week if we are to keep
to those timelines around being
completed and out of the way in time for
the openings of those developments
it is a significant change to what the
design of the street has been done
if we are making that change to angled
parking would completely require
changes to the sizes of that that
pedestrian zone
on the southern side of the street and
really
we would what you would be doing is
sending us back to revisit
preliminary design if we go back to
revisit preliminary design we simply
won't make those timelines
so the comments were made the other day
about once we've you know
we have a look at the preliminary design
we move forward we're on the express
train through to construction
we can't get off so if we want to make
those timelines
the preliminary design is in front of us
for adoption today
correct um council a lot lower than
council lewis
thanks for the clarification um
i'm not going to create roadblocks
because of people's
parking ability or lack thereof um
but i stand very firm and around
there needs to be good communication
with the
not only the members of the wider city
but particularly with the people
who are trying to operate in this area
through this time
okay council louis thanks chad just a
very quick question
outside glasses and s street and flight
center in that area there's quite a
number of presumably seats marked on
this that plan
is there any chance perhaps one extra
parallel park could be put into there
that would not involve a lot of change
or even change our decision whatever we
make today
i think we're going into design here
i think uh we we are not designers as
councillors
we are here to adopt this preliminary
design
designed by the experts we've engaged
i was just going to say when we come
back to like changing habits i don't
know about you guys but if i ever go to
need and i drive straight into the
meridian center park there and i do
everything
so i i think that that is a habit that
we are going to adjust to very very
quickly and i'm
very sure i'll still pop over to the to
the shoe shop
and they're from being parked there and
i think the advantages
you know as a retailer probably in my
view that how i feel about things
is going to be more of an advantage than
a disadvantage
with what's going ahead in the city
block
a huge advantage thanks for that
perspective uh councillor sopa
thank you mr chair i wasn't going to
speak but i thought i would just make a
little comment it seems to me
um that that there's a big decision here
is us accepting
that we're we're agreeing to a concept
about people first and the vehicles are
the visitors
on that basis i like this preliminary
design
and i would like it to go ahead on the
on the timeline
um and i think if we accept the people
first concept
then to some extent we're accepting
that that has consequences about
parallel parks or
engel parks and that
we if you like pinning our colours to
this being a
preliminary design that's gone through a
great deal
of thought consultation
and several meetings already that have
have arrived at this point so i feel
very comfortable about
voting for it and the full knowledge of
what we are saying except
thank you councillor abbott yeah i'll be
very very brief i've just taken on board
the
parking issues that were brought up by
the team and uh i've been
listening to the prospect of
communication
and i really think that uh us as a
council
and you as a team john can actually
re-educate people
and send them to these alternatives
alternatives like the wilson
alternatives like the 11th street car
park i think we just need to put some
education out there
okay right all right
um we've had it moved and
seconded we have the full
recommendations up on the screen
i'm now going to put the motion all
those in favor please say hi
hi i'm against just because of the power
of our parking and not giving
consideration to the elderly
i was disabled i was going to ask for
the against so would you like your vote
recorded
okay uh with that motion has carried
thank you
councillors
closing the meeting yeah
you